la imagen ha provocado especulaciones en
la última década en mayo de 2012 cuando
vladimir putin fue investido presidente
por tercera vez mijail gorbachov asistió
a la ceremonia está firmado pero nadie
sabe lo que dijo a partir de ese momento
se volvió muy crítico con el presidente
ruso y sostuvo que tres mandatos
presidenciales son demasiados
un año después habló públicamente del
tema en una gala en su honor en eeuu y
luego en un programa de radio
yo aconsejaría a vladimir putin que se
fuera ya ha tenido tres mandatos dos
como presidente y uno como primer
ministro tres mandatos son suficientes
se están creando planes a su alrededor
vladimir putin habló de la caída de la
urss como una gran catástrofe del siglo
20 con una crítica velada a su último
líder no obstante mijail gorbachov apoyó
a vladimir putin durante sus primeros
años en el poder e incluso le aconsejó
apoyó sus esfuerzos para que nuestro
estado sea más eficiente con el fin de
establecer orden en el país cosas que se
pueden cuestionar pero creo que su rumbo
es el correcto en realidad la relación
entre los dos hombres fue ambigua
los dos hombres coinciden es en la
necesidad de ampliar la influencia
internacional que le pertenece a rusia
legítimamente en lo que son radicalmente
diferentes es en que putin no es
comunista bajo ningún precepto mientras
que mijail gorbachov era un comunista
convencido el ministro araque mijail
gorbachov un comunista con aunque
gorbachov no llego a decir mucho sobre
la guerra en ucrania su fundación emitió
una declaración dos días después del
inicio de la invasión rusa en la que
pedía el fin de los combates y el inicio
inmediato de las negociaciones de paz no
obstante unos años antes gorbachov apoyó
la invasión rusa de crimea